[Applaudissements]
il a tout débriefer lui je vous dis là
ah ouais t'es jeune voisin week-end de
foot est partout mais je pensais pas
quand même nous retrouver à côté de vous
à poil c'est quoi ça lui qu'il est un
site entre les deux je me sers et c'est
très fort alors attention vendredi cyril
hanouna a présenté parce qu'on va parler
de la grosse rigolade de la grande
d'arcueil de balances ton post alors
répétez nouvelle émission la grosse
rigolade et le casting de fou comme
l'avait dit le cas si vous voyez les
chroniqueurs c'est que de la télé balas
et l inverse
ça n'a absolument rien à voir j'ai
regardé le résumé sur télé-loisirs je
passe au début c'était oasis à ce qui se
passe comme résumé sur la grosse
rigolade
1 c'est quand je vous lis comme remède à
la morosité l'animateur trublion propose
l'émission spéciale consacrée aux rires
tout ça pour faire chauffer les
zygomatiques bouquin écrit c'est pas
vrai je la battais n'a bien joué comme
ça c'est exceptionnel
juste avant de partir donc je les nie
c'était incroyable vous aviez avec vous
une femme qui nous fait mourir de rire
chantal ladesou bah ouais tu sur scène
ont invité le fait quasiment rire tout
le monde à chaque intervention
donc vous êtes dit qu'avec sa façon de
parler il entend raconter des blagues
serait extraordinaire ouais le problème
c'est qu'à n'a fait que des bee gees
c'était pas les gérants palace outre été
génial c'était chantal en dessous
regardez
[Musique]
m
chantal se rencontrent avec effroi que
sa blague n'a pas fonctionné le problème
c'est que désormais à chaque chute c'est
un bide répéter dans ce cours d'anglais
cinq ans de leur image lisse est ici qu
en anglais à 5 euros
if his between
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu lui as dit eh bien je
lui ai dit c'est un pari montréal c'est
pas la marée de léo je lui ai dit que
les premières classes n'avait pas
montréal le 20 la mi mars il menait mais
pourquoi tu avais qu à changer de place
baillet personnes pour demander alors
j'ai pas changé alors comment être
possible qu'une des femmes les plus
drôles du monde capable de faire rire
même gini mohamed enchaîne les bills
pourquoi chantal elle soit soudain perdu
le pouvoir de faire rire mais parce que
cette place est maudite
en effet chantal ladesou est assise à la
place de cette personne
un copain qui semble une excellente amie
qui s'appelait soutif et les gens à bord
et parce qu'il disait ah ben tiens
quelqu'un n'a jamais eu pour une fois le
sort avec un soutif journée pourquoi
c'est vrai c'est la plaie vous en ferez
une grande jeune grosse rigolade vous
offrez une avec neuf volontiers c'est
vrai alors la semaine prochaine on est
complet semaine d'après aussi dans trois
savez j'ai peut-être une place à la
volée semaine d'après casting de
fonction des courbes et on à alban on
n'a rien gagné du ciel on a chip lui
aurait on n'a qu'à me le loup je crois
comme ma chérie parce que à mesure que
j'ai failli vous invité ce soir et on
était complet poisson prochaine avec
attention l'autre hostile jeudi dans
balance temps peuvent vous aviez un
invité fil rouge le controversé yassine
belattar alors il a passé une bonne
soirée le gars en face à l'équipe
et comme ça se fait pas ça il est
chroniqueur série vous avez fait une
belle surprise
faire entrer un de ses pires ennemis
issus du rassemblement national
j'en mets siat l'armée sac a fait une
belle entrée sur son chanteur préféré je
pense d'abord aux bonbons je finis juste
avec lui non parce que je me sois plus
de son nom je me souviens plus bien sûr
fait de tellement médiocres n'ont pas
loyer et je m'en fous dans la vie de
prédateur
alors les bonbons pensée pour l'apéritif
mais le plat principal était l'invité
mystère nation et vous dire un truc il
ya un invité mystère chaque fois qu'il
vient c'est pas le déficit c'est la
guerre mais si j'ai l'impression
moi j'aurais mis d'autres musiques
d'entrée par exemple
à
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]
s'ils doutent alors qu'un a d'ailleurs
fait un sketch dans son nouveau
spectacle je vous le dis il a fait
vraiment un sketch de son passage dans
ma lance ton post je vous montrerai les
extraits demain journée j'en ai pleuré
de rire ah oui poisson à lui s'attendait
une surprise croyez voilà c'était sacré
soirée genre son prof de bio 3e et 10e
en fait c'est le gars voilà qui le mail
que je dis ça et après après ils sont
comme ça maintenant les deux à bon
amélie 2 ne se lâche ça sans parler on
va voir voilà une ambiance de fou entre
les deux parce que j'en mets ça qui
vient tellement souvent ici qui va finir
par vous demander un salaire donc et on
va voir que belattar ms-l cm au tango
jimmy mohmed eric naulleau franchement
c'était cordelle comme me rends compte
vous allez voir moi je suis content de
te voir je sais pas toi à moi que tu es
bon tu sais pas s'il est vrai que
j'avais jamais vu deux personnes aussi
contente de se voir sur dire des choses
aussi gentille et au fn messi a alors
bonjour fils de me dire ça bonsoir
raciste de bienvenue soir l'origine un
tu me renvoie mes origines leur ton
visage et très bientôt donc monsieur
yassine belattar dit que j'ai une tête
de chameaux que j'ai une fête [ __ ]
été obligé de porter un pin's de la
france pour qu'on sache que tu es le
français mon cousin du lycée bissett
c'est encore raciste mais c'est le
tennis alors je l'aï montré quelques
temps que jean messi a rêvé d'être
chronique les ans dans la grande dar k
il est aussi bon que laurent gbagbo que
le site français pour me rapprocher de
gens ici présent c'est la marque je
porte parce que ça me rend plus français
c'est que le made in france comme ton
slip alors
comme ça les gens mais ça c'est pas été
du goût alors si tu confonds booba
yassine belattar il faut dire que vers
les indes en octobre ou d'intellectuels
évidemment aller il a du talent et grâce
à yassine belattar on assiste à un
événement sur ce plateau
on a toujours vu jimmy mohamed comme
sahin jamais un sourire jamais un rictus
quand soudain si moi l'humour nazis un
humour je te laisse les races
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
franchement on s'est régalé et record
d'audience pour balances ton post jeudi
soir merci à tous une super ambiance
une super ambiance le plateau mais
heureusement chevaux que j'avais été une
nouvelle fois très calme avec tout le
monde
ah ouais avec toulon très calme de
classes et d'écoles drake lâché tout le
monde est accomplie et tout le monde a
pris on connaissait le tarbes alors
découvert le cousin un style un peu plus
le cache
c'est cyril clash luna comme d'habitude
c'était le bordel sur le plateau que
vous avez montré votre patience
légendaire genève surprise de yacine et
la laisser parler les gens en place sur
son portable
ça y est vous commencez à clasher tout
le monde notamment donc raquel garrido
qui n'est pas assez rapide pour moi que
sa question ça vous énerve et c'était
quoi la question exactement là que c'est
une question comme elle est posée tant
elle est écrite
oui vous savez soutenu la candidature
d'emmanuel mâcon 2017 le soutiendrez
vous en 2022 c'est pas la peine de le
passer par des des slaloms jean luc
mélenchon est tranquille chez lui en
train de relire sa propre autobiographie
et vous le mettez place
donc on était bons jean luc mélenchon et
c'est assurément pas passer mon potager
il est cuit maintenant dans la justice
c'est l'enfant chez mélenchon il est
dans les armées syrie on l'aimé bien
regarde et la nouvelle rosa médias ne se
souviendra longtemps de sa deuxième
émission je pense qu'ensemble on appelle
simplement megève à retourner sur ses
new skies si vous n'êtes pas le juge de
l'émission
non mais je veux être là pour mettre des
vagues sur les machos il n'est pas géré
votre note sur twitter et on sera très
content juste et puis pour finir c'est
karim zéribi qui est tombée sur l'animal
mais la situation la fin de celle un peu
plus grave que tu avais arrêté
aujourd'hui à fait le droit de faire des
vagues sanu maury je ne parle pas des
yacine arrêtez arrêtez de tourner pour
tous égal il a arrêté de terme et
intellectuels is et et intellectualiser
intellectualiser du moment où on est
bien traité la même pression après ça
j'ai écouté et organismes et folie te
dire ah oui ça partait dans tous les
sens bas vous avez été bon orthophoniste
bio j'ai adoré 660 mille téléspectateurs
bravo merci pas
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
alors enfin c'est un autre moment parce
que donc le jeudi on est votre casque et
d'éditorialistes polémiste le samedi
vous remettez la casquette du petit
trublion du paf avait la vente d'art car
on s'est régalé à ça c'était magnifique
vous receviez juin le père sava et
quelques mois plus tôt c'était patrice
laffont sa place quand on vous l'aviez
demandé ce qu'ils pensaient julien
lepers
en un mot patrice à mes yeux un joli
qualificatif m'ont rappelé qu'alors
comme vous aimez bien mettre une bonne
ambiance dans vos émissions vous avez
montré à julien ce grand moment où
patrice laffont déclare sa flamme à son
ami cyril je vais le père s'arrête
autres imitation préférées et pourtant
on en extrait vous aller chauffer le
pauvre julien lepers comme jamais julien
lepers julien lepers [ __ ]
remarquez je suis le seul à partir du
nom disent pas combien l'embrouillé pas
pourquoi et bien leur bruit pourquoi
c'est gratuit je ne sais pas mais ça
c'est gratuit apple est ce que tu es
capable
on l'appelle on l'appelle a tant donné à
l appel et attend il ya des millions de
gens qui regardent pas me laisser faire
et moi c'était dans pu les prisons
direct je m'appelle julien lepers est
aussi vrai que je m'appelle julien
lepers
je voudrais que tu es le courage de
décrocher son téléphone et de me dire
pourquoi tu me traite d'enculé devant
tout le monde devant des millions de
gens dans les émissions de
cyril hanouna est ce que tu peux
m'expliquer pourquoi je suis un [ __ ]
moi je ne sais pas je t'embrasse patrice
recul est vraiment chronologiquement la
cirgl a donc entendu et le père c'est
patrice laffont dire [ __ ] déjà c'est
magnifique
et aussi incroyable que d'entendre goût
va dire la fontaine par exemple donc
julien lepers il est ultra chaud mais en
plus vous faites quoi vous les mettez
baffie dans le rival chauffer encore
plus et il va encore plus défoncé dans
les staffs ont regardé j'encule patrice
laffont tout le monde ya des millions de
gens qui regardent les fous qu'est-ce
que tu le voudrais voir écrit surtout
d'épitaphe heureusement avant de mourir
j'ai tué cet [ __ ] de batista
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'au bout de quelques minutes
quand même vous avez rendu ouf le pauvre
bien le père et vous allez lui avouer
qu'en fait tout ceci n'était qu'une
vaste supercherie
vous avez fait en fait un montage de
l'interview de patience à fond et
forcément je vais le père s'il va se
trouver un petit faucon donc il va
vouloir rappeler patrice et les pilotes
de l'histoire et non julien lepers
je m'en fous alors alors dix ans qu
laissé pour nous alors julien lepers
julien lepers [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
patrice c'est ton copain ton ami ton
frère
[Applaudissements]
à dire de moi que j'étais un [ __ ]
enfin tu le penses pas du tout bien sûr
je t'embrasse partout mon petit à petit
ça bientôt bisous c'est julia l'enculé
sur patrice laffont et julien lepers mes
chaussures journée pleut je continue à
les ignorer nos rires fous j'en
éprouvais de rire